so I think it's the woman's fault
because the women tend to leave and they
tend to leave for stupid reasons yeah
but then my argument is that if you
believe like the natural order is that
like men are supposed to lead and that
women are socially submissive there's
obviously something wrong with like
leadership if some women are so
willingly and easily okay so I would I
would argue it's because men have no
power in this Society they know that if
they leave that they lose
um they they know they lose everything
honestly if if it doesn't work out women
know they gain everything if you pay
people to make bad decisions they're
going to make bad decisions